bah tiens tu fais ce que tu veux je te
montrent d'abord on va partir en
week-end ah ben oui y'a côté d'en boire
à sport et tout et tout alors je vais te
dire tu vas voir alors je te montre ses
murs alors je tournais le musée juste
avant je voudrais que tu regardes met
toi bien la méthode il ya là j'aurais
bien que tu regarde ta tête
hier ton blouson le blouson que tu avais
hier est ce que cet impôt ou pas parce
que tu as fait une facture de 1200 euros
je crois à la production d'avril et
revenir là dessus et calais qui
l'envoyaient la production alors que le
blouson n'était pas lui alors non matoto
non non non mais attends je vais
t'expliquer on va revoir
on va revoir vos têtes hier il s'est
passé un truc de ouf et benhaim regarder
la taïwanaise de beinheim et regardez
vous vous êtes surtout plein par rapport
à votre blouson et vous avez donc
demandé à ce que ce blouson vous soient
remboursés alors que le second qu'il a
volé non vie imola vols annoncés oui
est-ce qu'on peut revoir les images
délavées tard alors leurs mots est ce
que voulait revoir les images d'hier se
fait poser une question voilà prête noms
pour y poser des sceaux devant la france
entière
oui tu me donnes tu me fais un cadeau
peu importe le prix maintenant il est à
moi sourit-il
donc j'ai demandé à ta production qui
d'ailleurs était charmante mais je peux
lui faire un tarif non mais je vous
dirais que vous voulez revoir est ce que
vous voulez revoir ce qui s'est passé
hier évidemment si vous voulez on va
s'est achevée hier
eh bien regardez ce qui s'est passé hier
[Musique]
[Rires]